so one of the stats we would uh andrew
and i would cite it's in his book
um the war on home people was hold the
book um but he would talk about
um what happens when men and women lose
their jobs
and so the job and particularly in older
generations
um the job was not just your job it was
your livelihood your purpose you are the
provider
you're the man you're the breadwinner
whatever definition but there's some
a lot of identity associated with it
particularly for men and
the numbers bear that out when women
lose their jobs they
generally stay like their behavior
doesn't really change they stay
productive they either become more
caretakers in the home
or they join non-profits or they get
involved in school and they
essentially stay flat in terms of their
overall well-being and productivity
men disintegrate men turn to by the
numbers um
video games alcohol sometimes drugs and
pornography
and suicide yeah yes okay and then um
they get depressed and um so very very
serious mental health issues
and suicide how have you seen that the
element of strength play in
and i really want to dive in because
there's also emotional strength too
which i think women
are based on what you're talking about
probably stronger emotionally than men
um so there's two different types of
strength here how much that
responsibility kind of weighs in on
people's relationship with their their
gender i guess yeah
i mean that's a really interesting
question feminism and gender equality
actually acts as a buffer for male
suicide okay
because what we find throughout history
is exactly what you're saying
uh when there's economic crises when a
lot of
people lose their jobs and particularly
uh
kobit was the first actually extremely
unequal recession
in history where women were the most
hurt but if you look at 2008 for example
the last recession we had men lost a lot
of jobs right
women did too but manufacturing jobs
right like when we think about the jobs
that were that were really lost um a lot
of men lost their jobs right
and so what happens is normally you have
an increase in male suicide
right when you have uh higher
unemployment with men because of
everything that you've said
but when you have a society
where women actually contribute equally
right that it's not just men or the
breadwinner and women stay at home
that women are the breadwinner too
male and female suicide rates are not as
skewed
and that's because you know the thing
you can infer from that
which the researcher who studied this
inferred this
is you know yeah when you put that
all of that burden on one person and on
one gender
and that and it's also on something that
you cannot control
i mean the both of us could lose our
jobs tomorrow right this is not
something that's
you know you earn right it's out of your
control but if
if if the only thing that makes you a
man
is being a breadwinner and that that's
no longer available to you
of course you're gonna think that you're
a burden of course you're gonna think
that
you're there's nothing good that you can
do you're going to have an a a crisis of
identity and that's what we're seeing
men experience and and in and again it's
like
if we could degender working if we could
degender
uh breadwinning as as an identity and
uh by doing that give men more
flexibility
and possibility and imagination about
how to be men
in society and how to be useful or you
know what their purpose can be
like then you have such an expansive
opportunity
and and you have men who aren't as uh
you know completely distraught and and
and destroyed if they lose their jobs
um and so i i think so much about that
about how um you know these
roles are made up well these roles are
just like
you know again we can go back into
capitalism and all stuff but like
literally
like these were just inventions like you
know
women of color have always worked like
like it wasn't a thing like it was just
like a white working-class model
right of the nuclear family that men
work and women rockwell painting
whatever it is yeah
exactly and so if we were to sort of
just
give people more flexibility when it
comes to that it would just make
everyone
you know much happier um and i just i
get so sad
you know to think that a man would feel
like a burden because
you know he's not able to to provide and
also
providing you know women provide by
doing all kinds of things right like
even if we think about prototypical
like a stay-at-home dad or mom is
providing oh my god
like that's providing care that's
probably mom um
and she worked harder than my dad in
many ways exactly
it's just more valuable than my father
did in my
dad nothing against my dad um my dad's
ministry
or you know the church's ministry that i
grew up in or wherever he is
one of the things like the most common
things you've got all we
bring all these men together which is
great and it would be called my dad does
one called iron sharpens iron which is a
bible verse like
iron sharpens iron a one man sharp is
another which i do think like
brotherhood and sisterhood i think are
really important for
particularly for men to actually talk
about this stuff um
but one of the things like the most
common thing we get at these it's wild
is that um
the men say their wives nag them um does
she's nagging me she's telling me you
take the trash out tell me never not
doing this
and what my dad
and the the conference would say to the
guys and i want your opinion on whether
this is
healthy or counter counterproductive to
what we're talking about here because
this is where
i think the devil's in the details and
stuff what they would say at the church
would be well she's what is she nagging
you to do what the question is
and well she wants to take the trash out
she wants to make the bed he's like well
um if are you the man of the house like
yes like well whose job is it to make
sure the house is looking good
he's like it's my job like yes so like
what is she nagging to do
bud she's not gonna do your job and like
thank god she's there because it sounds
like you wouldn't [ __ ] do it
so michael and like when we tell men
this we
being like the the the leaders of this
um a light bulb goes off
um and to me i always felt like it was
shifting their definition of masculinity
where i don't have to be like yeah rao
rau you get that for me
it's like no i'm actually here to help
and support you and and
some protection some love some like but
it like a responsibility piece
thoughts on that like how off base is
that church in florida talking about
that at the moment
i think that's wonderful and again it's
like i think it's such a great
way to frame this conversation right
that
again i just want to de-gender [ __ ] like
i just want to de-gender like
like yeah keeping your home clean like
that should just be something you
do period like like not something that
anyone has to
yeah like ask you to do because their
gender is right and
and you find this with um lgbtq couples
lgbt lgbtq couples
are just have high levels really higher
levels of satisfaction
in their relationships than straight
couples because there's no norm
it's like who fits if this is what the
man is supposed to do and it's two women
yes it's just like what do you like to
do and you know it's our house and how
are we going to
there's just some more equitable
separation of
of work because there's not
predetermined rules that are made up by
who
the [ __ ] knows and um and and there's
more freedom right it's all about
freedom like
truly it is about freedom and you know
with your example the other thing i was
just thinking about which
really again is such a it's such a
detriment
to our society that we consistently
um are trained not to listen to women
and not to believe women and to blame
women
like we blame women for everything
and it is so again i mean there's
examples of you know we blame women for
their own
sexual assault like it we blame women
for
right like not smiling enough and talks
about being dehuman where you look you
don't
look at women as as equal exactly human
it's a dehumanization
that needs to be taught you know what
i'm saying like i think it's
biologically
if you're just caveman i don't think
that boys are like that though
like i don't think that there's
something natural again it comes back to
the research separating you know
and i think we need more research that
asks these nuanced questions that
instead of seeing men as a monolith
you know is interested in how they you
know yeah what they believe
about masculinity and how that ends up
determining a lot of different things
like
like i think we we assume certain
biologic
we did this with women right we assumed
women were just
kinder and on their periods and more
emotional
and it's like these things are so wrong
like
emotional do you want to get you want to
talk about how like every war
like it's like in history like and and
this is not to say again that women are
more specific but
but we have we've create you know our
our society creates certain rules
certain norms certain scripts
and then we follow them and then it's
like i want people to
to to be interested in figuring out who
they are
authentically right and maybe it means
that yeah you're a go-getter and you are
you have more of an
aggressive personality right in in that
way and like that's who you are there
are women who are like that like
it's fine but is that really who you are
or are you playing a part and and when
it comes to again just
listening to women that's the you know i
think everyone wants
something that like a marriage that
doesn't end in divorce like i think no
one's like
in it to like divorce but the number one
uh factor that leads to a lasting
marriage
heterosexual marriage is a man that
accepts his wife's
influence okay and this is from the
gottman institute they've done
years and years of research on this and
it's very simple right it just means
when she says something
you listen when she says something you
you you don't say no you're wrong or
oh you're making things up like the way
that we talked about women in our
[Music]
society
[Music]
you